so
eagle has landed that's another book
that's a
one that's uh
did you read that book by chad to help
what's the guy that's irish
okay hi everybody so what's the
what's the situation on uh how many
people know the answer to the secret
code
if anybody
inside
kathy you and your team
what i have the solution to the second
one but not the first
the second one i haven't had time to go
through the first one yet the program is
working but you have programs that uh
that were able to help you with the
second or did you do it all by hand
and uh
and onio
you you claimed to have i had yeah i had
both of them
okay
okay so now are other people uh
everybody's studying for the for the cop
there's a little exam coming up on
saturday
the last exam it's under your right the
last exam of your life you know i might
as well enjoy
so i understand that your sympathies
aren't entirely 100 with this course
today is that right
um
the
the uh uh but do you have teams anyway
and somehow yeah guys are all okay
now the the
the thing i wanted to talk about mostly
today is the idea of interaction i think
we
mean those of you who
have solved it and maybe even those who
haven't solved it will realize that
the need for interaction in a problem
like like this the machine you can i
don't think we would take a machine that
would it would come up and say i've
solved this this problem unless the
machine somehow knows
the something about
how to distinguish solutions from
non-solutions the way people do
and there are
probably zillions of solutions i don't
want to estimate how many there are
really
but
i think only one
as you see
and you might still not agree but uh
look at that last week but i i really
believe there's a unique solution to
these to these cryptograms but only
because
uh it has to make sense after so so
therefore a human being has to be in the
loop
now um but what kind how what are going
to be good ways to uh not to have a
human being in this loop i mean we sold
human beings going to be there to
evaluate things and maybe suggest
directions but what should the
what should the person be doing so let
me get some ideas
on this from the people who haven't
solved it yet
and also from those who have and we'll
see if they
maybe are the same or different
um what do you think
i'll start counter-clockwise pain
who are you working with oh i'm working
with uh arrive and
dimitri
okay
and so so far we're
designing stage of the program you mean
you're studying for the car
what are you doing what are you
designing so you're trying to design a
program that would that would do what
kind of thing that would produce some
output i mean since we're like playing
hangman
you have um
you just assume
let's just say a string is probably at
this position and you put it in and see
if it works and if it works then okay so
so you so you have us a conjectured
string and a conjecture position
and then you have a program that puts it
in sees if it works yeah okay
well that's interesting that you brought
up hangman you know one of the problems
that i i considered having for this
class was
to find the hardest
word in hangman
uh using a you know use a dictionary of
english language and try to figure out
which uh
which would in some sense be the most
difficult hangman word
i thought it would probably come out to
something
some three-letter word with different
unusual letters but i wouldn't but
anyway it might
turn out to be an interesting problem
for another 204 someday
but this is uh
but but hangman is a pr is a is a
guessing game where you
i see you get partial it'll say that
some of the letters are in there and the
rest of them are still unknown and
that's
and and here we have 256 unknowns and
we've some things are going to flash in
and say oh yes here's one
yeah i see it's a similar
similar uh idea okay so now
um
uh
the first question then about this
the position of the string and and so on
how are you going to present this
information you've got 200 256
characters
some of which are known and some which
are unknown how is the how do you tell
the user
in an effective way
how does the user figure out what what
position
you know does he say
is it in position number 137 and if so
how did he know that
you know how
how did this number 137 uh
did he sit there and count up 237 or how
does he how does a user specify a
position have you worked on that at all
in your group
orifice
just that
tries out all the all the places which
have not yet been tested out i mean all
the places where it could fit in it
gives you all the places at which it
could fit okay
and this is the corresponding uh
transformation which is that i mean the
resulting partial passage so suppose it
fits in uh in five ways it gives you
five it you know
so you specify a word like program and
it says program could occur in these
five places
and and then what else do you show then
and it shows the partial passages which
result from making the substitute
partial substitution for f oh i see so
so uh you
you'll have
let's say in the case that program
occurs in five ways
you would have five
examples where one of them would say
program here
and it might also say
um
it might also say a lot of uh
nine something right and then this one
might say program here
and it might say uh
right curly brace
q
exclamation point or something
and and so on each one would
would put program in there and also
other consequences as well as everything
else you've assumed okay right
so now um
and what if there are
what if there are 80 of these instead of
five of them can you forget about
and you can't prune it to a smaller size
then the word is a bad choice for i mean
for well maybe uh the word occurs a lot
let me know
for instance have curly bracket q
exclamation mark right okay and that you
know is a very unlikely thing yeah yeah
okay so you could probably drop out that
one but after doing that because that's
at 80. okay so
yeah
no so so bad so yeah after that they're
still left with 80 then uh you wouldn't
want to even try one uh well yeah you
would you would go ahead and
try a better word okay
uh now um but it's a little bit like uh
like a search in you know in a database
library for example where
where uh you say uh you know give me all
titles of papers that that include the
word program in them and then
the uh
the library that the it'll say you know
i found
1384 references and so then you say okay
let me let me refine that and it should
also have the word structure or
something in it
and then you get down to something where
you can list them all or like the new
service program something like that
where we have um so so it's in a way we
we have a lot of data inside the
computer and it'll present until finally
there's a small number of things that a
person can look at so then he doesn't
have to
you don't have to to know that this is
in position 100 and
whatever i said 139 wherever i got the
difference about the the point is that
over here you don't know what other
words should be in the thing you're just
making in the first place you have a
program you know it has to be there but
let's say you guess that while is there
you're not certain it's there anyway
that's right okay while okay or yeah
right begin is another one it's got to
be there begin end look at these but
beyond that
right very few things which are certain
okay so now so anyway then person can
just say the third one or something like
that or how is that the way you wanna
yeah then you pick out one of them
and uh sort of
do a depth first search from
um now let's talk about what what better
so so then now it's uh you're thinking
of this as a tree and here was something
where we had nothing known and then we
might have five branches
of that are displayed there and a person
says
let's look at this one
and try to
try to explore and score that okay
and then then they're back and then
they're at a situation where like your
person types in three and they see okay
here you are now it says
what's your next keyword that's right
those aren't necessarily disjoint
paths or branches they aren't
necessarily disjoint okay
and what do you mean disjoint
that is that it might be true that
program appears more than once is that
what you mean
for example a program might appear more
than once
you know if any word appears more than
once that you're searching for you'll
get
two of those and then they would both be
consistent with each other in fact they
both they might be consistent right so
so the fact is that uh
that
in fact um
well let me
let me take an uh
suppose that you said
program a it was your keyword program
space a was your keyword
and it found uh maybe that program space
a could occur in different places in
there
and you might go down the tree a long
ways
but and you might find consistency
although reading the true message says
program b
but program a doesn't look inconsistent
at the moment so it says no it's
possible for you to to actually go down
the tree with things that are consistent
and uh and the final message
uh and and really you'll be wrong
but but you'll still be able to decode
uh a great amount of message even though
there's something wrong in there
uh
do you see what i mean because because a
and b that's only off by one little
small part of f and that might not
propagate
some parts of f seem to propagate to
large parts of the message major parts
are
are fairly easy to twiddle and change uh
since they don't break down and they
probably won't harm anything else so so
any so in this tree uh he even though
the user will can can imagine probably
that he's going down one branch but it
doesn't necessarily
mean that uh
that
the other branches are wrong
or that the branch that you're on is
right
but but the but probably as a as a model
as if they were disjoint what harm would
their what harm is there if you assume
that they're i mean if you pretend like
they're disjointed just continue on
and keep exploring as if they were
disjoined i'm not quite sure why
non-disjointness is a
is a consideration in writing the
program
um
no i i
mean in that sense i meant that
you can't
if you if you choose one of those paths
in fact two of several of those past may
correspond to the same eventual message
and uh that's true
only if they
if only if the word occurs several times
which is which is conceivable if you
have a common word like the
uh it might occur a lot right i tried
once
in one of the things i i tried this just
a key word of space you know single
letter space
and it uh
i had 90 some
places i could put a state so it didn't
help much but uh i just wanted to try it
to see
um and uh and i in fact i did have the
machine construct a
an example by putting in as many spaces
as it could and then i put in as many
e's
and i and then t's you know i went in
the order of frequency of letters
in in
in english text and uh just to
get a message that would
sort of be the most probable in some
blind sense of single letter frequencies
um okay so so now uh uh
uh
dimitri is there anything else uh that
i'm missing in this design here
and
so so the idea for this is then um one
of the aspects of the interaction will
be then to
to be presented with the partial
solution so far and uh
and a key and then time for the user to
type the keywords
and the keyword and then and we display
the uh um
possible choices to go from the from
that keyword
what how do you display this message as
far as the other places that are still
unknown i
put on this let me ask to meet you i
think as long as you guys are all
working together how do you think
we use that
character like underscore son
what character underscore yeah what was
the first
song some
that is not used in
i don't know
okay so so you you you found a character
that
that was sort of uh uh
indicating no that you would use for
for representing um uh representing like
underscore and we assume that the
message doesn't have too many
uh
underscores in it uh for example pascal
programs
theoretically don't have underscores in
them
and neither do english
uh texts uh very often although it's a
nasty character okay so underscore was a
was a fairly
uh
it's i guess it's even the way we used
to play hangman when we were kids as we
put undiscourse
uh in place of the unknown letters
what about what if you find a
carriage return
how do you indicate that
how does the user know that you've found
the carriage returning in a certain
place
so far i i don't think we have covered
that so far just write out
the message with person
i don't know what it does in that case
maybe it prints out carriage written in
regular brackets or something
it might blow the fuse you don't know
yeah oh i see in other words pascal
you've heard it's not writing out the
letter
you're just saying chair 13 in this
and this uh this uh probably uh
does return the carriage
and so does uh and no would just
disappear entirely probably
zero
okay um yeah uh
what do people think about that
we got to represent you know we got to
represent uh more than um
we've got 94
visible symbols and a space
and three others that could be in the
message
uh
according to ascii code anyway
and but we we have uh
so that's
but we actually have 94 plus space and
three others
plus not yet known
so that's 94 so we have uh
uh four other things to display to the
user
uh
then
uh then we have symbols available to us
for for display
so
the way the way
the way my program handles it is it uses
two it uses two letters um to display
each letter so if if you've worked out a
letter it will be displayed as space for
example if you worked at programming
space p
okay um and return is um character term
which is the third thing is slash r
new line is slash n
backslash sorry
what is it unknown and the unknown is
done is a right a left curly brace
followed by right curly brace
okay so in other words you're sitting
here with something like this and then p
r
o
slash r
like that if somebody put a character in
the middle of
okay so you you made up a two-letter
code that would that would um that would
give you this
and uh and since you're one of the
people who's who solved that least
problem too
um it must have been visually acceptable
to see patterns that i had i had an
example of what it looks like spread out
oh you do okay well let's put it on the
screen
oh wait a minute
what about the very first step
it doesn't have courage return in it
or anything or anything interesting it
it um well
okay
i think
you ran out of this space yeah okay have
you you've heard about the solution of
that problem right we've got the
accounts for everybody who are included
i have these files that are deleted
which i hadn't cleaned up
well that's uh
still there's uh uh
some people are operating with limited
accounts that are supposed to be good
enough for mail but not good enough for
solving cryptograms and so uh i if you
can
you should tell ramsey immediately and
then
then you get more uh and you get a
better account okay uh
the uh uh
now i would like to show at least the
beginning of the
of this uh
just so that you could see that this two
two letter uh
this thing actually uh
uh
just not doesn't seem to be a hindrance
let's uh
randomly cover up the bottom part of the
sheet but just leave a leave the first
two
two on there
uh i'll warm this guy up too
okay now
so so the the question of presentation
by the way uh
i
uh
is it going to be clear
when a person sees a lot of these
where is where
where the keyword is
i mean
if i were
if this were being uh
written um
uh
if if we had a
macintosh or something we would
highlight this we would highlight these
words but we're writing a program in in
uh programming language that was not
where our our output statements don't uh
uh give us a convenient way to flash the
screen or whatever it is uh uh because
those languages were designed before
there was much hardware that would do
these things karen you have a comment
well it's kind of our hypothesis that
if we're trying to optimize on the total
time taken from the start of solving
this problem to the time when you say
you know eureka or whatever
um
that the display will be a really
crucial feature of it the ease with
which
you know the user can look at this
display and
and make guesses and see patterns that
basically anything you can do to make it
easier will be very important in the
team okay that's the critical yeah the
critical thing is to uh is to somehow
uh get to get through so that you don't
have to do too much translation it sort
of feels like
like a joystick or something where you
where you can just say okay go there
yeah
but that's even more important than
super powerful commands
um and so
well we can argue about that one but
this is our hypothesis yeah but so um
we were going to try to use one of the
packages to get rid of it
and rich and john
okay
reverse video right
to do some of that kind of thing
so what programming language are you are
you working on
so and and you're working on score or on
boxes
on navajo
so uh you've got an easy way to get the
reverse video on well there's a cursive
package there's a what a package called
persons which does this is screen
manipulation
okay
yeah
so you have a terminal
screen thing so see i've never had it
i've never had a chance to use a package
like that and i began to feel
the need for it only when i work on a
program like this which needs a lot of
interaction otherwise a lot of the
things i do are you know i'm happy to
just get ordinary old pronouns
but this was exactly the reasons that
karen says
i want to
have something that will focus my eyes
on the right place and not have to spend
a lot of time
figuring out what what to do uh
that was
that was uh
a problem now see
this thing still doesn't
look on oh okay
um
uh and so
for example i was working on sale and i
had and i think i used uh
the equivalence sign
uh for the
you know unknown characters just one at
a time and then i would you i had to use
something like a an equal sign for for
no because we got we got more we got a
large character set on sale but we don't
have an easy way to flash
on the flash characters
ultimately all right
by the way the the uh
dennis told me that he would have this
camera only hooked up to the
to that uh you know it wouldn't be
hooked up to the main uh uh uh
would never show me on here for example
of course
but we might try this to see if we get
infinite uh
oh wait a minute can somebody see it
okay so anyway here's an example then of
how uh
kathy's program looks with uh
with the left and right curly braces uh
for for nulls and with program look at
that she found program right at the
beginning is that a surprise to anybody
we're giving this away
um
and uh
beginning excuse me that was the program
which finds that word you say you want
to guess a word and it goes through its
table of words and they're just in the
letter paired distances
it says distance 12 here so yeah oh yeah
the first thing it does is reads a file
um of words and calculates interleaved
distances
um and then it uses that when you say
get when you type g which means guess it
uses that to look
um to see whether it can fit any of the
words in its table into the cipher
okay okay well let's go back and talk
about that later because uh yeah because
that's another another uh
issue that i want to try to keep one
thing on the table at a time yeah
um
and uh so so uh the main thing that that
there is a you have printed a grid here
along the top though going 0 1 2 3 4
and 0 32 64 224 what's the function of
that
that tells you the place that that
allows you to calculate the the number
um like you can say
if you want to add if you want to add a
letter you can say exactly where you
want to add it in the site in the in
cypher so you might guess that the
letter after the end will have to be a
space and so you can say okay from that
you can calculate that that's number
seven
okay now let's look let's uh so you
don't have a mouse for example
that just points to other place or a
touch screen or something yeah
and uh
and i just i guess i should just wanted
to give my
30 seconds
spiel about wondering how long it will
be before things are standardized enough
that we could assume uh
some kind of of uh normal conventions in
in
many programming languages without
having
you know everybody
everybody on every different machine
having some
some other uh
way of doing it for because of course we
have so many different machines and
this is probably going to be one of the
last things in programming languages
that gets uh that gets us solidified
even the i o that we have now took
another 10 years after the rest of the
programming languages were fairly well
understood
i was chairman of the committee in 1963
where i remember somebody on the
committee was saying we can't
we can't come up with any standards for
input output because nobody understands
input output yet you know you know and i
and i said to the other people on the
committee well look we've been looking
at these problems for five years uh by
now we certainly we certainly understand
more than we did five years ago and
we're ready to go and finalize it now
that's that's what i thought was was
true in 1963 well
things are still up in the air 1985.
in fact some of you were weren't born in
1963 is this true or not
i guess maybe while you were almost born
in the 60s
right you know conceived anyways
so uh
uh
and there might then you know then uh
once this gets solidified something else
will come along but
but for a while but somehow um there's
this dichotomy between people who think
that input output is isn't part of real
programming and those who
who think that it's the only thing that
realizes
and uh it's it's because it has it's
because it's uh it depends so much on
on
hardware that we think is uh is
developing fast we can't get a handle on
it we can't really make a decent
long long-term prediction about what's
the what's the right kind of a standard
to to uh
to decide on once and for all on the
other hand we we sort of agree that plus
sign should should be should stand for
addition things like that that's
much more stable
okay now let's see on this um
thing then uh
it it does seem that the two-letter uh
presentation is not it's not really a
hindrance as far as recognition is
concerned uh having it having a
two-letter having spaces between the
letters doesn't uh
uh
doesn't look distracting to me uh unless
i had a message with a lot of spaces in
it or i might be or it might be hard for
me to to track
spaces but presumably
that's not
you know that would be the only defect i
can think of in something like this
well notice that
that uh some some other things slashed
in here um
uh
this looks like a left left parenthesis
the this must be a right parenthesis
and a letter and a 9
came in those were implied by putting
a seven letter
a program into the thing i guess so
and
uh so i
um
at least this is this is a a way of of
getting around the fact that you don't
have enough characters uh if you go one
character per character you don't have
enough characters to display all the
possible data the other approach that
people said was that well we actually
some of those ascii characters we know
because
because of properties of pascal we know
that they aren't in the program
pascal was invented for a 64 character
machine after all so uh it has to be
possible to write
pascal programs without it although i
could have been sneakier and
and made it capital p-r-o-g-r-a-m it
didn't occur to me until last week that
i should have done
that in the middle what switched cases
switched cases in the middle
all right
program yeah right
this is the opposite of an anti-gram you
know you could have
um
and and uh
uh
so uh in fact it looks like i used
lowercase uh t there didn't i
um
and that would and maybe would have been
harder for people to
to do it because it's more convenient
for us usually to type on our terminals
now with lowercase
um
all right so so english text also
doesn't use all of the all of the uh
our characters that are involved there
there's
not very many novels that have
backslashes in them and
except you know user manuals for
typesetting systems but
one of the
other big needs is to is
to have a few more visible characters
that nobody uses
just for purposes of display
things like this i think it's an
interesting
issue that when we start talking about
text as text and so sort of computer
scientists
dealing with
with things at a meta level
one level over uh
every character that we have
that that isn't
um
isn't commonly used in the text that we
that our programs deal with every such
meta character is a treasure
and we you know the fact that we have
these uh
a backslash and we have uh
some uh
a stat sign or left string quote or
something that's not on a typewriter
at signs are on typewriter
the
sometimes
you get square brackets that are in
programming languages and not even on
ibm
terminals i guess
um but every every uh
uh
new character that's that we that we can
display
but but doesn't appear in the in in the
kind of text that we're doing uh seems
to be
extremely valuable once in a while and
uh if that if that had only been
realized by the people who designed
these standard character sets that that
that
a few more
a few more characters could really help
in designing
systems i have
in the tech
program
are people using this in all different
countries and they have different
different languages for their alphabets
uh
russian language has 32
letters in alphabet instead of 26. they
the norwegian language has 29 characters
norwegian danish swedish have and they
so they have
they have to go into these extra
characters
like backslash and so on that are that
are uh
that we use for delimiters and they
don't even have that they don't even
have those because they're
they're they're taken up by letters in
those
in those uh system so for presentation
of of information
uh
extra enhanced character sets seem to be
helpful and one way of getting around it
is by going to
two characters at a time i did
any other ideas on how to present
how to present this partial solution of
a message
so
okay i think we were going to try two
columns for each one so that adjacent
letters would
be next to each other
two columns like two uh two rows sorry
so that
some a single character would be
represented by
a little column
okay
okay i see oh you would have a you would
have a carriage return indicated by a
maybe a c uh
oops
a c over an r or something like that on
two on a two line notation right right
okay
yeah oh okay that's uh that's another uh
good idea i think it's uh
it uh
uh
and
so so an emphasis on this kind of visual
that the corresponds with our
whatever it is cortex uh
uh
something that will flash in uh well is
it is an important part of a good design
i think for an interactive program
these two line notations are interesting
from
that
i guess uh the the very first
programming language in history the plan
called cool of uh conrad souza was a
four line he had all the inputs on four
lines and and every and you would have
to have to write your program on four
lines
uh
these molly line things have been
are difficult on input systems i think
but for output display it can it can be
useful
um
the
the the the
program that i use for inputting musical
notation now has uh
you you give every line of music on
several lines will you specify uh
rhythm
uh
with on one line and and pitch on
another and things like that
well
um
now what about let's go oh i'm sorry i i
was coming back to that you guys and
just after you
because uh the the other thing i wanted
to talk about kathy's program was to uh
uh that this this these numbers on there
for referring because she had this idea
that she wanted to be able to
essentially point to a place in the
message and say now
let's try putting a comma there or try
putting something you know a space at a
particular place
and uh i would like to uh
to to talk about that so so so let's
take a look at the
at this beginning thing and suppose i
wanted to try see there's a uh
a nine there
suppose i wanted to put a semicolon
right after that nine what should i what
do i do
you you would talk i um for the x add
command
and then on the next line it would then
you type return and on the next line
um it would say which character do you
want to add right now you've got a
choice you need to write type a
semicolon then return
or if you wanted something like a null
you put slush then then the number in
decimal okay so that way you can put in
a character and be sure of getting a
character term or whatever okay okay so
i have somewhere specifying that as a
semicolon okay yeah and then then next
line it'd say whereabouts do you want to
put it and you just type a number okay
which means you have to add for example
you'd have to add 224 to something if
you want to put something on the bottom
okay that's uh yeah okay so now by the
way i forgot to ask you kathy who are
you working with i'm working with mary
anne she wrote the first part of the
program um to
go through the
words and
pairs
okay you didn't work together on the
first problem did you
you worked the other way around you're
another no no no no
no no i was like you're currently new oh
that's okay i thought i just wanted to
to
try to keep also moving people around
too okay so now now we you have to add
to 19. yeah and uh and if that's easy
for you then you just say 51 but if it's
yeah okay now is there a way that that
addition could be speeded up that's the
issue i wanted to rate according to what
currency is there an easier way to to
point
um yes you can make a matrix or if
you're not using if you're just using a
print like that you can make it a matrix
whenever by whatever or i could just
make it so you're adding something which
is a multiple of 10 because that's a lot
easier
yeah so there's no there's there's the
mean
here we've got 32 in a line
if it was 30 it would be easier
you could do it like battleship what's
battleship
uh
international fid way of writing test
moves
um
okay uh
so
it would be like in an editor you
actually sort of
keep giving spaces until you come to the
position spaces of some whatever
character for you have a going forward
let's say control f and
so you would have a cursor you'd have to
have that you have to have a cursor
that would make the program
significantly more complicated i tried
to make this fairly simple i didn't want
to spend all my time on it yeah before i
wanted to try some uh okay so a week
from monday is when our a week from
tuesday is when we want to demonstrate
all these programs
by by solving
a cyphers as a group here
and i want to have a
have some kind of a computer in class on
tuesday so that we can we can look for
bugs in that installation beforehand and
i'd like to to try to work out by then
how how easy it is to get some of these
uh
like
the curses uh
pro things uh if it's going to be
possible to
to see it in this in this sub-basement
room where we are now so uh
we'll try to shake out the
bugs of that kind but
next week just so that we can have
something to display on the screen and
then we'll have the real problem-solving
session a week from then actually i
think there's a fairly painless way to
do this but i'm not quite sure if it
works which is
um emacs allows you to
build your own commands so you could you
know
basically edit your crypt file and write
little emax commands to search for words
and stuff which we call your own
routines so you'd be running emacs at
the same time as yeah emacs would be the
top level it would be calling your lower
level routines wouldn't you have to
write it in tco
no no no that's why you you've pretty
much seen that so you've endless but i
think i think almost allows you to call
this i'm not quite sure that's a part of
it okay so there would be that would be
a way of getting cursor in there and
then you would you would you would find
your position uh
by
by by clicking keys quickly instead of
by instead of by uh saying uh row and
column coordinates that's right okay so
that's a way of pointing uh
uh
with uh with a keyboard as felt instead
of with your finger oh my mouse yeah um
and then but if you have coordinates uh
something that minimizes the need to for
mental addition is
is useful and did you also have uh can
we go back to that one again
did you also have um
okay now um another thing is i would
recommend if you have something like
this you could print out something on
the
on the right hand side in the bottom as
well as on the left hand side and the
top
because the farther away you get over
here
uh the harder it is to to to to see what
line you're in and you know
i only put that grid on it this morning
okay yeah last night when i decoded it i
did it without the groove without the
horrible
well i must confess the way i did mine
uh i had to play you know it would show
places where i could hit instead of
displaying programming this way i would
have one
you know it would show the uh the entire
thing and then i and i had a special
character that would go in in five
places in the message and that would be
those would be the places that that i
could put
put the word and then i would just say
choose the third of those or something
like that but if there were
if there were
20 of them and i was choosing the the
17th
i you know i would have to really go
through and make sure that there were
just exactly three after it or something
like that um and uh so okay i miscounted
a few times but it did take me i mean
consciously i had to sit there and you
know
that's taking time
um and uh if i did it wrong then i could
always back back up and and do it again
but uh
uh
that but uh
the the as you as you get to working
with the program you'll see you'll see
uh these ideas will i think come
spontaneously that you that don't occur
to you
when you're first designing it uh and
this is one of the
reasons why uh
i think uh
well you have to live with a with any uh
interactive system uh before you before
you have any confidence at all that
you've got the right one you you can't
just do these things on
on paper and uh
um this is uh something to keep in mind
when people say that never write a
program until you've specified it
completely
this is uh has to be tempered with the
fact is that when you're living with a
program you think of new specifications
uh
constantly
um
even
a program like uh
like like tech for example that i had
it i kept record of all the changes i
made to it over a long period of time
and
and uh
uh for a period of four months uh i
would get one new idea for how to
improve tech every two days this is sort
of a steady no so every two pages i it
was
over some um this was not over i i
didn't get to work on the program
constantly
but i was i was entering volume two
throughout the time so i calibrated the
x-axis of my scale was
how many pages i had typed in a volume
two
of my book and uh and then every two
pages i would get another idea how i how
that could have been better
uh to handle that you know and that this
kept on going steady until i had gotten
until i had typed up uh
about
uh
500 pages and then on the last hundred i
didn't get any new ideas at all but uh
for a long period of time over over uh
you know
several months period uh always like
every day every time i would start out
in the morning i would think yeah now
tech is complete there's nothing more to
do
because i now have a system that i want
and then two pages later i think of
something that was a big improvement
and that's when on and on okay so so
with interactive system i think that's
that's also
typical like kathy said she just added
something just this morning and and uh
you keep thinking more things to add too
and the more you live with the
um interactive thing and uh i guess
another moral of that is that if
if you're if you're the designer and the
programmer but not the user
uh
you might not come up with the best
system
uh
because uh it's while you're sitting
there work working with with the system
that you think of these things it's not
when you it's not when you're off in
another designing tower uh that you
think of them it's when you're actually
sitting there using them so it's
a system for interaction i think
the designer user have to be the same
person
uh in order to do a good one
anybody want to challenge any of these
things i'm saying or add more
just speak up
now um
let's see uh
then
the next question
is i guess i promise to come back to
what you were saying that you have a
different way of going at it then
you had a
g command on your thing as long as we
have this
this to display we might as well make
milk it for all it's worth we keep can
we get this back on here again now at
the beginning it says type h or question
mark for help
um
now what this is you know
types h or question mark for help that's
always uh
uh makes it seem friendly i guess
what if you type exclamation point
what so i didn't forget these one little
commands i mean it's easy to forget yeah
oh okay yeah that's uh
that's right there are one another
command so what if you type exclamation
point then
it will wait until you type something
which is
there's lots of all kinds of ways to
interact but uh somebody says g well
this was and there was distance equals
12. so let me let's go into
algorithm
mode now for discussion what is distance
equals 12 means that was left over from
the output from marianne's part of the
program which i haven't which at the
moment still writes out i haven't i
haven't got rid of that output yet but
what does it mean what it means is these
are all the words which have two letters
which are 12 apart
oh okay and there are no words there
so so so i'm sorry you've listed yeah
marianne
um
i made kind of a dictionary of all the
pascal keywords and oh i see all right
let me see that so this is the list of
all the
keywords right program
and const elf forward and so on yeah
other words that are more than two
letters
um
and uh where did you get this
list
just by looking at it
okay
because right no it means the press
would have forward in there because uh
it's left out of the index of the most
pascal book somehow
um external isn't any okay yeah okay
then i ran a program on that um
and that's fine that would search all
the words that have um the special
property we mentioned last
last time okay that is
a distance of uh
uh for programming it would have a
distance of five for example
yeah oh yeah exactly so this is the
object that i got
on this
oh okay so in other words it starts out
and it says distance equals oh i see
that's that's just left over that's not
a distance equals 12 does not uh
uh replay it does not uh um
i mean that we're now sitting at a
situation which uh we're 12 steps from
the end or something like that
okay
um
and uh for an output uh
uh it turns out to be a very good one
because it has two butts in it is that
right
um except um
okay well yeah i guess output is a
is a normal way to get
output
it has two ups and an input has a nut in
it also and then those are those are
distance one packed has a distance one e
d function has it an o n
procedure has an e d and const has an o
n so that's and then there were at
distance uh
uh five program was the longest uh the
longest such hit
okay function has a has another one okay
so that's interesting so that's what
that's left over from okay
now then
okay so that program has run and then
now what and it says
g well that was i type j and you type g
yeah
and that means
go for it
well yeah i guess
go for what that means that means
stop from the beginning of the file and
start from the beginning of the cipher
and look for letters look for what
letters which are however many
look for letter pairs anyway which are
less than 12 of the parts first of all
it starts the first letter and sees if
the one next to it is is only one apart
okay so now we're looking for two places
where
where you've got uh c k plus c
c k plus k equal uh equal to each other
that are such that are a certain
distance apart yeah that's right okay
and then it tries
it okay once it finds a possibility
um it writes it tries it and writes out
the cipher which is what you the psychic
text that it gets which is what you see
on the screen there
um
so this is the first one that i found
yeah that's right okay okay because
there's no there are no distance two or
just there's three ones in that word and
anyway okay then it says do you want to
but
wait a minute there were distance one
want words though how come it no it
starts it's like it starts at the
beginning of
the of the light of the
cycle
and it looks like
oh at the beginning of the cipher okay
yeah okay all right so this was the so
from starting at the beginning and going
toward the end that's why i found this
one because this is the first
coincidence of any of any kind
and
yes and maybe that's the same reason
mike uh
noticed it too
could they uh
okay last week so so uh there we are
right then it asks you if that looks
okay so when you when it finds
um a word it prints it out so you can
see if it's put anything strange it
already checks to see if it would write
any invisible characters or anything
like anything nasty
uh right it wouldn't even uh put that in
there if there was a controlled if it if
it meant something to a control d or
something like that it wouldn't even
bother displaying that
some illegal character then it would if
they wouldn't even consider this as a
live possibility as well
so let's already check that and then you
have to look for anything which seems
like strange pascal syntax or something
like that so for example if it wrote a
plus sign straight after the mn program
then you'd think that that was a bit
strange and you'd probably say that
right right okay all right okay right or
after or left yeah
anything can go in comments but uh
yeah right
that's right in fact you so there are
where as you're recording a message you
get things that
that seem
implausible
and some things that seem definitely
wrong to you but i guess there's
there's sort of the same idea like when
i was solving my wife's uh the one that
my wife presented to me
um
uh
it i got i thought i was i was fairly
well along with the with the solution
but but all of a sudden here pops up a
five letter word
starting with capital h a y
and i say now wait a minute i must have
made some terrible mistake
i couldn't think of any uh any uh
mistakes though in the other parts of
the message but here's this capital h a
y sitting in there and
and uh
and uh so i thought certainly i would
you know i'll find some some problem
there well um ten minutes later i
realized it was hayden
and uh then vivaldi fell right into
place and i knew that the whole subject
of her message was music and things like
this but uh you know sometimes you'll
there'll be
patterns that that don't look correct
that turn out later to be others that
that that don't look correct and really
aren't
and that's the the latter is usually the
case
and i said now wait a minute i must have
made some terrible mistake
i couldn't think of any uh any uh
mistakes though in the other parts of
the message but here's this capital h a
y sitting in there and
and uh
and so i thought certainly i would you
know i'll find some some problem there
well
ten minutes later i realized it was
haydn
and then vivaldi fell right into place
and i knew that the whole subject of her
message was music and things like this
but uh you know sometimes you you'll
there'll be
patterns that that don't look correct
that turn out later to be others that
that that don't look correct and really
aren't and that's the the latter is
usually the case well you can there is a
facility you can undo
you can analyze
this do you want to undo this
so yes
yes no and and right so so now undoing
means a lot just go back once go back to
the map you had before you tried putting
that word in
and keep and
and so just and then you know what else
you want to do so map is uh is the f
function that
that you have and so at every step you
have a certain map and you have a
previous map how do you go back to the
previous one
oh i have two copies it's not very nice
right just two copies yeah i have two if
you undo twice um if you want to undo
once you've once you've got that word
there
um if you don't undo it at this stage
uh the next chan the only way you can
undo it is by undoing single characters
at the moment this is only
um this seems acceptable for the
starting point yeah yeah i mean at least
at least unless you get somewhere it
lets you down okay so there's a but no i
i'm not
asking you to defend your program now as
being the final the final thing but uh i
just wanted to raise the issue of uh
undoing and and so on so so the same
thing occurs in the solution and we were
talking about earlier we have a
we start to walk down the tree and uh
and uh we'll we'll get to
you know we'll we'll make a few choices
and uh
and uh we'll
we'll want to finally get we'll get to a
point that doesn't look like uh it was
right choice and so now we have so
in general that the backtracking or
undoing to get us back to a previous
situation
um
i was wondering if people had a thoughts
on how
on a
good way to to handle this for example
uh
you could store the entire contents of
your computer memory at every level
and uh and then read it in again from a
file uh
sort of uh
you know if you if you have this backing
up procedure or the question is how much
do you do we really need to
to save at each point what's a good way
to save it uh
the question of of undoing is primarily
a data structure problem seems to me
uh
as we go through
as we go through any problem that has a
chance of backtracking and going and
taking back something that we've done
we either have to uh store all of our
forward motions in some reversible
fashion or else keep uh
some
checkpoints some
enough of enough information to
reconstruct the whole state of whatever
is needed in our program
at some point so what are people's ideas
on this
for this kind of thing let's see i'll
get to
uh i might be i'll bring some more
people on uh
see karen you've spoken rich so you're
together
uh
all right i've got two andy's in a row
here what do you want
to who should i pick on i'll pick you're
smiling so pick up
well i guess uh probably the simplest
thing to do is as you said just store
the checkpoints and also store the
commands that leave from one point from
one note to the next okay so for example
these are our checkpoints you know level
zero level one level two well you don't
have to make them every single level but
oh i see at certain levels
yeah um
you could store logical dependencies if
how everything was derived what what
everything needed to get your eyes and
then you could actually find okay now
that's very abstract let's talk about
concrete for example what would i store
at
a at a place uh
suppose i'd move to to this
you know to adopt this solution uh what
would i store here would i store uh
the the
the uh
current contents of the plaintext uh
uh the current contents of f uh the
current uh
uh
the contents of f i think should do it
um
it depends if your program is doing some
automatic processing like
it if you say one thing and it and it um
produces lots of logical consequences
then it has to remember that those
objective consequences were caused by
that move right so when you undo the
movement under the consequences oh well
okay so so we get consequences of a move
that affects f but f is your main data
structure right you have because
certainly if you have f you can
reconstruct from and we have c that's
never changes i mean our c k plus k
that's stored in somewhere that's global
that never changes but as f changes so f
changes at different levels and then
um we might have auxiliary tables that
that tell us about our partial solution
method but if if we don't then
at least
that's one of the my idea uh obvious
characteristics about f but at different
levels is that
it
it's got more entries filled in
uh
and and is that
maybe that's the
the main abstract property of it if i go
if i go down a further level this means
that f has more slots that are known or
constrained but never doesn't have any
previously known slots are changed in
order to change a slot in f in order to
change f of
um
i would have to come back to a position
where f of 28 was not defined and then
move forward but there's no
whenever i move down i never
negate any of the previous
f's
of f values i never change any of the
values that were known i only add i only
make it more
more known what is the
word i only refine the function or
whatever it is uh
there's a problem there in that if you
find out that so you say you try to put
a certain letter in a certain place so
you find out that f of 28 has to be 135
right you also get the f of 135 has to
be 28.
so that that much can be easily undone
but suppose that we find out that f 28
has to be 135 you've got some other
numbers say 67 which you knew before
could either be
135 or 182
right and so this is how 28 goes to 135
means that 67 has to go to 132.
instead you know
if you feel like you've um wiped out all
the possibilities for
another number except for one then you
have to bind that one as well and then
when you go to undo 28 then you've got
to know enough to undo
67. and put back this the possibility
that you had for it for it right okay
put it back in every place now replay so
so when you're making a
when you're making a uh a logical
deduction uh then uh you have to
you you have to have some kind of a
backing up table that says this was
deduced from from that if i take this
one back i got to take all these back
too is that what you're saying yeah well
i'm not advocating this but i'm not
advocating it but you're mentioning it
yeah i think it moving the course
information to the store funnel
um yes that's a mess i mean it's a lot
easier to move in the forward direction
by storing one or more checkpoints
okay so in other words you know
when you it you would you would have
checkpoints that
that uh let's take a suppose you take it
at every even numbered level for example
and uh instead of having a set of at
every level where you store off the
whole works and then if you wanted to go
back from level
six to level five you could go you could
go back to level four and forward one
that's right that's what you're saying
the trade-off would be you know as usual
time for space if you want to store
every state then you can backtrack
really fast
if you want to um if you just want to
store the initial state it'll take a
long time to recreate the previous
stream
this is going to be an issue in problem
three also and in any kind of a thing
where or possibly in problem three i
think anyway so one of the one of the
ways of attacking problem three is to
is to uh
would be to uh have some kind of a
method that that's backtracking and
and uh
keeping and going undoing uh
consequences of previous uh
logical decisions it seems to be
important in lots of
heuristic search
activity
sorry
that um that you haven't been to i mean
it seems like we might have a state
space
graph instead of tree because
suppose you put if you don't undo things
in the order that you did them
like you add f add g add h
then you want to take out f then you're
to a state where you had g and h in a
certain
yeah that's place interesting point that
i i found that when i was selling my own
thing i i ran my program five times as
it turned out i started out and i would
go for ways and
and i would
and i would get more and more deductions
and so on but then all of a sudden i i
knew that
that there was some some problem in my
partial solution
but i had made you know maybe at the
second level i made a bad choice but i
went and made 10 good choices after that
and started you started to see that
there's a you know there's a word
significant or something popping into my
into my uh
uh plain text and so i knew that it was
significant except that it it actually
what popped into my plain text was
significant or something you know
something
that i knew the real way was significant
but
the reason that x was there was because
of a bad decision i made f long ago you
know at a previous level and so i i
would get to a point where where i was
getting big pieces of the message but i
also had had
glammed onto things i shouldn't have
and
then i so so you know i would stop and
start over again
uh
but my my first guess as to a word to
put in
would be you know some 50 long character
string that i was sure was there
yeah with my program you can recover
from that sort of mistake because you
can change single letters you can you
say in your example if you had
significant or something like that
you'd say okay i want to change i want
to undo that letter and then you can go
back and put another letter in there
okay so that says that that you that you
then are
are updating your f somehow based on
based on what on the visual uh
on on what was displayed and somebody
could say change that to a that x to an
n well uh what else uh gets in other
words there might be some other letters
in there it would it would make other
changes but how would it know that's my
question see how would it know
what understood
you're saying change this letter x to an
n no matter what other
and anything else that's inconsistent
with it
uh overrule that too is that what you're
saying well it's actually done in two
steps the first step is you undo that
particular map which is oh okay
which is like i mean you can undo
that particular the x was sitting there
because f uh that's right of
something f of two is equal to three
okay right then the next thing you do is
to say okay add that add the the correct
character in that place
okay and that would and that would check
for conflicts and stuff like that okay
and if so and if so it wouldn't let you
add it it wouldn't let me change the
actually because it would be another
conflict yeah so you may have to undo
other things it would tell you where
that conflict was
the sort of conflict you would get is
something the conflict sort of conflict
i detect this kind of conflict where
you've got um a character which you know
a non-prince one of the characters which
is not asking you're not not visible
yeah
um
if that was if that character was going
to turn up it means that that particular
map would have been wrong surely
well maybe uh
but the x was wrong too that's what i
mean so so maybe i had two errors it
should have been moved to long line oh
yeah so that's they it's uh getting to
see if there's some other if i knew the
x should be an n
but this machine isn't going to let me
change the x to an n because uh
uh this would mean
something let me see does that ever does
that ever arise maybe it doesn't it
can't happen because the
only thing that's happening when no
eight or maybe it can so you go back
again
to change an x-ran you say it takes two
stages first i undefined the reason why
the x appeared
undefining is always harmless it can't
introduce any new contradiction inside
but but then putting this putting the x
you're putting putting an n in there
uh it now what i'm wondering is could it
lead to a contradiction that's only a
contradiction because of something oh
yeah some other assumption that i made
yeah
actually even unbinding something can
can very occasionally lead to a
contradiction if if you're using a very
uh if you're using what problem solving
that uses the
the visual principle as well right my
program doesn't use that yeah and so i'm
not going to have that problem
but i might have other problems
well you just have one you have to
um no at the moment it doesn't tell you
where the conflict is so perhaps i
should change my program so it tells you
where the conflict is so you can undo
something further if you thought that
was necessary
i don't still don't see what kind of
conflict there could be yeah well let's
try to see if because i i do remember
vaguely when i was writing my program i
i
there was one simplification say oh yes
this kind of
thing can't can't mess me up but i don't
remember what it was
let's see if i can
go
let's see if we can think of a
of a scenario
could this happen so i've i'm sitting
here and and i've and i found the word
significant
and
all of a sudden i realize that that's
probably
an n right this is what we're getting at
okay so i want to undefine this
first of all
thanks i i want to undefine this uh and
um
uh and now for in the this first step
roger is saying that this might also uh
lead to
lead to some thing because he he made a
uh the fact that x was
okay so x this the fact that this x was
there was because f of 2 was equal to 3
and f of 3 was equal to 2
for example in in uh
let's say and i'm gonna get some
concrete numbers in here and so by
undefining the fact that i had an x in
here um
maybe that just says that f of two is
now undefined and f 3 is not undefined
it can't be a contradiction because
there's always something that satisfies
it namely what you just had in there
no but if you had say if you had f
2 narrowed down
to i mean let's see f of two was never f
of three
whenever you remove constraint you just
whatever you then have will include what
you just do you've still got constraints
though on the on the f's by what like
say if you've got a certain
if two appears at this point in the
message it appears at this point in the
message and you know that they both have
to translate to visible characters in
both places
then you know that f two has to map to
some number between say 63 and 67. or
part three
or 63 to 67
is what you said there right yeah right
and
well basically either
well either you could find either that
could be even narrower where you just
know that it has to map to three
or there could be something else yes
down to that narrower range
if it was only three then we then of
course uh it's going to be a little hard
to undo this uh
but it was only three because of
other things in the message i mean the
reason that these that this other 6367
was currently eliminated was because
there's something else
happening in the message
that that uh i mean this wasn't my only
error in the message maybe i've done
got a bunch of other apps are also wrong
um
and so the fact that but whenever so for
example um
uh suppose somebody had i'm not sure
there's no limit if f of 63 let's make
it just 3 or 63 to make it simple
suppose that
that f of 63
was um
what's up i don't know
what 42 42
all right
goodbye that counts for 42 is 63 okay
now
um
uh so
so then this possibility wouldn't appear
in our in our data set anymore it would
look like f of two couldn't you know had
to be three or nothing
and so we're using data structures
yeah
uh so he was using a forcing table that
would that would uh say that as soon as
as soon as you get to a role that has
only one possible position left he
he jumps to that conclusion that it has
to be the the position
and and uh before that before the f of
63 was put in so f of 63 was filled in
that that took away f of 2 and forced f
of 2 to be there and forced us to get an
x in the message now when we take that x
out somehow
we've got to
know to take out f of 63
which is somewhere else in the message
this is the i guess that they issue them
the way we do it is we keep around the
illegal possibilities also and just have
them applied as illegal so when you back
up you can actually remove the
flag
a flag well in some sense we have
another list that has other information
to keep it to say
which ones are
uh legal and illegal of the possibility
okay so you have you have uh
yes you have a uh um
sort of the
uh level zero uh implications of the
whole thing where in other words uh
every uh before any other assumptions
have been made uh
at least you know that f of two could
only be such and such and then there are
other higher level implications that
have been made that have been put on top
of that you would have three and 63 in
there and somehow mark the 63 is kind of
good at the moment
not at the moment okay
and if you back up then you could
re-awaken that
and we also have the possibility that
you can commit yourself that is say that
store these
because it does take a little bit longer
with all these possibilities
and so you could actually change the
table
and start from there then you couldn't
back up over that unless you recomputed
the whole table
okay and recompute the whole table means
of all the uh
new possibilities and so
and so that's a uh uh
so so uh that's the other issue that
that came up suppose and i say after
i've undefined this now i want to put an
n in here
now putting an n in here is mike because
might
might now be saying f of 2 is 63
and that would mean that f of 63 is now
2 instead of 42 and
and i'm going to have to change
something else and this would this is
kathy was realizing
might not allow me to change this to an
n because there's a
there's a somewhere a conflict uh
elsewhere in the message but it wouldn't
tell me what the other conflict was and
so you would have to so so the fact that
this would change
to another one would would really you
know undefine f of 42 and change this to
a two
as well
and
that
depending on how much
how much deduction you're doing in your
data
this would this undefining wouldn't be a
problem but
uh but if you're doing a lot of the
deduction you have to take kind of every
only finding stuff as well as every
defining step
and so that would that would lead to a
conflict saying uh you know you can't
change this to an envy unless you change
this
uh to a a uh
a three over here something like that
and uh
and then the user should be able to say
okay do that too
or or you should be able to say i know
this is an n
anything that it conflicts with remove
that too just sort of you know don't
don't tolerate any
any uh dissension
okay
now let's see
what groups haven't i heard from yet um
andy you're working with mike
mike okay roger are you working with
bring in the deal
and uh
and uh that leaves john you know you're
with
with richard amy
okay you and annie
and john okay that that's a complete uh
set okay
so what um
what let me see what else can we
talk about here what what issues are
there in your
approach
so far yeah comps times okay
so uh
okay that's fine uh
two minutes on comps
so uh
well let me just say that the uh uh on
on tuesday we'll want to we'll want to
uh uh see how how much problems we're
going to have into getting
getting the
uh the the
uh results of of online computations
into this
into into our class so that uh week from
tuesday everything will work smoothly
the uh
uh but what is it going to be like a
week from tuesday well i somehow have
this vision that we that you might have
a better idea for but tentatively it's
gonna it uh i think we will try to
to use everybody's program um
uh
to do part of the job
in other words we will log into to one
system we keep at random and we see we
can get some
some advances into the
into the cipher then we
stop there and uh
and uh start on somebody else's program
but with a with another plausible
keyword maybe this isn't fair to you
know it's not symmetrical but uh
i i don't
think
we can really have five
groups uh all
all working
on the uh you know just against time to
see who's going to solve it first and
then have a play-by-play coming over
here and say okay in this group
i'm not sure how many motives we need
but uh you know
but then nobody else would i guess
everybody else could watch it on
videotape afterwards and see what the
other the other groups were
right
well i've got my uh assistant here to be
to to help me with the commentary on the
uh for color and uh
we can do we can do instant replays what
we're envisioning a tournament style
yeah
so
okay well if you want to uh try to
imagine something like that you can do
that too i was uh
just
wondering if we could all work as you
know somebody would say oh i bet you
that word is cryptogram or something you
know and then we'll try that and nope
doesn't work
um but uh
well we can still we can still design
what the final demonstration day event
is the main thing i want to make sure is
that we get to see everybody's program
in operation on that day somehow
that's an absolute deadline it's not a
terminal and uh it works well
see that's that's the the kind of issues
that we that we need okay
okay thanks a lot i'll see you on
tuesday
you